he that walketh with wise men shall be
wise
words kill
words give life they're either poison or
fruit you choose
knowledge is of more value than gold
[Music]
the sleep of a laboring man is sweet
[Music]
better the anger of a friend than the
kiss of an enemy
for as he thinketh in his heart says he
one man pretends to be rich yet has
nothing another pretends to be poor yet
has great wealth
a fool is wise in his eyes
the spirit can bear any illness but who
can bear an ill spirit
riches are a stronghold in the
imagination of a rich man
in the day of prosperity be joyful but
in the day of adversity consider
lazy hands make a man poor but diligent
hands bring wealth
train up a child in the way that he
should go and when he is old he will not
depart from it
money is the answer for everything
he mocks proud mockers but gives grace
to the humble
above all else guard your heart for
everything you do flows from it
as the lily among thorns says my love
among the daughters
as the apple tree among the trees of the
wood says my beloved among the suns
the slacker does not plow during
planting season at harvest time he looks
and there is nothing
[Music]
let us hear the conclusion of the whole
matter fear god and keep his
commandments
for this is the whole duty of man
for god shall bring every work into
judgment with every secret thing whether
it be good or whether it be evil
my beloved is mine and i am his
in the day of prosperity be joyful but
in the day of adversity consider
both of these things exist so that man
will not discover anything that will be
after him
better is the man of humble standing
that works for himself than one who
plays the great man but lacks bread
one who is slow to anger is better than
the mighty one who rules his spirit then
he who takes a city
comfort me with apples for i am sick of
love
start with god the first step in
learning is bowing down to god
only fools thumb their noses at such
wisdom and learning
[Music]
a wise son makes a glad father but a
foolish son is the grief of his mother
the tongue has the power of life and
death
[Music]
there is a time to weep in a time to
laugh a time to mourn in a time to dance
wrath is cruel and anger is overwhelming
but who is able to stand before jealousy
[Music]
there is no man who has power over the
spirit to retain the spirit nor has he
power over the day of death
and there is no discharge in war neither
shall wickedness deliver him who is
given to it
pride goes before destruction a haughty
spirit before a fall
for everything there is a season and a
time for every purpose under heaven a
time to be born and a time to die
a time to break down and a time to build
up a time to cast away stones and a time
to gather stones together a time to keep
silence and a time to speak
love is strong is the death jealousies
are as cruel as the tomb
rich is taken by wrongdoing do no good
but doing what is right and good saves
from death
[Music]
thanks for watching subscribe to the
wisdom of the ages channel